pro era una primera dama más pero el
golpe de estado de militares y
empresarios hondureños en 2009 contra su
marido y presidente Manuel Zelaya la
llevaron a un primer plano
a un gobierno usurpador
en su tercer intento de lograr la
presidencia se ha alejado de su marido
ya utilizado como una de sus bazas de
campaña ser la primera mujer presidenta
en la historia de Honduras un país
tradicionalmente machista y conservador
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este sentido prometió aprobar el
aborto en tres causales y ampliar
derechos para el colectivo LGBT q como
el matrimonio igualitario
además promete un cambio político
después de 12 años de gobiernos
conservadores salpicados por casos de
corrupción y lazos con el narcotráfico
su promesa de construir un Estado
socialista y democrático ha generado
virulentas críticas de la oposición que
vaticinan que Honduras va a ser una
nueva Cuba o Venezuela
temores en un país que igual que el
resto de la región sufre de poca cultura
política y suelen aflorar autoritarismos
personalizas por lo que un fracaso en el
reformismo podría acabar con las
esperanzas de su promesa de una Honduras
libre soberana e independiente